Vincent Cassel et Tina qu'on ailleur
[Musique]
y aurait-il de l'eau dans le gaz alors
il y a pas de sujet mais c'est la Une de
voici qui nous dit que le couple serait
en pleine séparation qu'ils ont déjà eu
des séparations comment on dit passagère
mais que celle-là ce serait la
définitive j'en ai parlé avec Florian
hier qui est pas mal d'infos et
paparazzi et tout ça qu'est-ce qui se
passe en fait déjà la presse people
c'est l'un des coupes préférés de la
presse people depuis 3 à 4 ans il les
scrutent ils sont sur eux voilà ce qui
explique que ça soit sorti dans voici ce
qui explique bien sûr et non la vérité
c'est que normalement c'est un coup de
très fusionnel qui sort beaucoup
beaucoup ensemble et qui vit ensemble
qui vit ensemble évidemment ils ont un
bel appartement dans Paris dans un
bouquin c'est parisien et récemment il y
a eu la Fashion Week pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est le grand événement
le grand rendez-vous de la mode à Paris
qui a lieu plusieurs fois par an et
normalement ils auraient dû se rendre à
plusieurs plusieurs événements ensemble
ils sont pas allés ça a alerté certaines
agences de pas paradis etc qui du coup
sont allés un petit peu planquer devant
chez eux voir s'il y avait de l'eau dans
le gaz est-ce qu'ils ont constaté c'est
que elle
l'autre partait et il ne se croisait
même pas donc et il y a aussi un autre
événement important ça que qui m'a été
confirmé
des Trois Mousquetaires qui est le gros
film de cette année en tout cas de
Vincent Cassel elle aurait dû être
présente elle n'y était pas elle est
partie en vacances avec une amie de son
côté Emma c'est mort mais vous savez oui
pardon La Fouine des réseaux sociaux que
je suis ils ont supprimé toutes leurs
photos ensemble alors que eux c'est un
peu le truc
machin ma petite Coco de colère ça peut
être un coup de colère
mais c'est trop long
à ce moment-là
non mais alors
c'est préparer etc elle elle a du
tempérament lui aussi je pense que c'est
pas non plus un bisounours dans 100
Cassel c'est quand même un mec test des
déclarations du genre
il faut quand même rester dans des gens
etc donc on imagine bien que ça doit
être de temps en temps peut-être un
petit peu explosif non ce que je trouve
dommage c'est pour leur petite fille
parce qu'elle a qu'à elle a 4 ans ou
quasiment 4 ans la petite
non mais ils se sont d'abord c'est pas
validé et puis si c'était le cas
divorce les enfants divorcés c'est
énorme mais quand vous enlevez toutes
les photos apparemment on est d'accord
que ça enlever toutes les photos en
premier a priori et lui il a suivi
derrière donc ce serait elle
Vincent Cassel en fait aurait été les
larmes aux yeux dire que elle lui manque
terriblement et que ce serait elle du
coup qu'il a un ami qui a rapporté ça il
dit qu'effectivement les larmes aux yeux
il a dit que il est toujours très
amoureux d'elle mais que ses filles avec
elle et c'est elle qui serait partie
personnelle bien entendu ils vont se
remettre j'ai toujours le vieux qui part
moi j'ai un doute c'est toujours le
vieux qui part ah ouais c'est parti
Monica Bellucci c'est elle qui l'avait
quitté c'est pas lui qui est parti et la
deuxième fois une petite chose encore
juste un petit truc pour revenir sur
Instagram parce que il y a quand même un
baromètre important dans des dans des
couples qui justement supprime les
photos etc c'est que normalement il ne
se suivent plus aussi et eux ils
continuent de se suivre donc je peux
avoir de l'espoir déjà on peut avoir de
l'espoir et beaucoup voilà après people
qui les suit attend de voir justement
les quatre ans de la petite Amazonie ce
sera dans une dizaine de jours
ils vont voir si à ce moment-là
très belle quartier pour cette semaine
il y a tout un dossier sur Vincent
Cassel il y a toute une partie au eux
ont l'air de dire que tout se passe de
nouveau très bien donc maintenant c'est
elle c'était son anniversaire il était
parents non mais on est tous d'accord
que ça d'ouvre en ce moment maintenant
ils peuvent se remettre ensemble de
nombre de couples qui fait un break et
vous le savez pas
[Rires]
tant que tu vends pas tu as pas perdu
mais c'est vrai que le break là quand
même il faudrait ouais
sur le même arme dans la forêt c'est que
tu es perdu 600 mètres ensemble au bout
d'un moment c'est une fois
qu'est-ce que c'est quoi ton proverbe si
tu tombes deux fois sur le même arbre
dans la forêt c'est que tu es perdu
qu'une fois que tu as cassé quelqu'un
faut pas se remettre ensemble
oui on a les mêmes lectures c'est pour
ça qu'on est ensemble ce soir
je vais offrir et tu dis à bientôt
voilà mais tout ça est au conditionnel
bien sûr et moi j'espère que c'est c'est
ça c'est des caractères forts
quand tu sors avec un artiste on est à
fleur de peau très difficile de vivre
avec nous autant
Bellucci il y a eu de nombreuses fois
des annonces de séparation ça émaillé
tout le temps
on en est là on embrasse Vincent